اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
معركه ارقام بين
اردوغانو المرشحان يستعدان لجوله اعاده
غير مسبوقه في تاريخ تركيا
يواصل حشد مزيد من الدعم العسكري قبل
المعركه المضاده وقواته تحقق اول تقدم في
محيط
صمود الهدنه في قطاع غزه والقوات
الاسرائيليه تقتل شابا فلسطينيا خلال
اقتحامها مدينه نابلس
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا جوله اعاده غير مسبوقه
في تاريخ تركيا سيخوضها رئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان ومنافسه زعيم المعارضه
صوت واحد المطلوبه لحسم الانتخابات من
جولتها الاولى وذلك بعد فرز اكثر من 90%
من الاصوات الرئيس رجب اردوغان الذي يحكم
قبضته على السلطه منذ عقدين من الزمن
والذي لم يهزم في اكثر من عشره انتخابات
وطنيه حقق بحسب رئيس هيئه الانتخابات تسعه
واربعين فاصل اربعه من عشره من الاصوات
بينما حصل كما سيجدار اوكلو مرشح المعارضه
على نحو
45% من اجماله الاصوات انتخابات شهدت
اقبالا قياسيا بلغت نسبته
88% فاصله 75 في الداخل وواحد وخمسين في
المئه فاصله 92 في الخارج وادى الاتراك
باصواتهم في اكثر من
91 الف صندوق اختراع في 81 ولايه من اجل
انتخاب رئيس جديد للبلاد لمده خمس سنوات
واختيار اعضاء البرلمان البالغ عددهم 600
عبره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهدين الان الى مفرده العربيه من
اسطنبول كريستيانو
وكيف تبدو الصوره في اسطنبول وهل حمله
عمليات الفرز اي مفاجات حتى اللحظه
اهلا بك وبجميع المشاهدين على ما يبدو
مستمره الهيئه العليا قالت بانه حتى الان
تم فرس
99.5% من مجموع الاصوات ولا يزال اي من
المرشحين لم يحقق
الخمسين صوت المطلوبه لحسم الجوله الاولى
اردوغان حصل على
49.4% على
44.96% وسنان اوغان على
5.3% وتقول الهيئه العليا للانتخابات بان
بقي 27 صندوقا داخل تركيا للفرز
و159 من الخارج لم يتم فرسهم بعد وبالتالي
من المفترض بانه خلال ساعات قليله سيتم
فرز ال 100 يعني 100% من نسبه
الصناتيق وذلك لم يتم بالامس لانه لان
الموظفين بطبيعه الحال اوقفوا عمليات
الفرس عند الساعه تقريبا الثالثه
الاصوات في بعض المراكز في احدى المراكز
يعني تحدثوا عن انه تم اعاده الفرز حوالي
11 مره لان جماعه اردوغان كانوا يرفضون
النتيجه تقول المعارضه ايضا بانه بالاماكن
التي يحسم تحسم فيها المعارضه يرفض
اردوغان النتيجه ولا يتم ادخال الارقام
النهائيه
واعتمادها من قبل الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات وذلك بهدف
يعني جعل الامور محسومه باتجاه جوله ثانيه
المراقبون هنا يقولون بان الجوله الثانيه
من مصلحه اردوغان لانه يمكن ان يعمل على
تفتيت مكونات المعارضه فهي غير متجانسه
وكان هناك دائما خلافات تحل في اللحظات
الاخيره فيما بينها فهي تضم القوميين
واليساريين والليبراليين والمحافظين
والعلمانيين والمتديين وبالتالي
على تناقضاتها من قبل اردوغان سهل جدا هذا
ما يقال بانه سيعمل عليه خلال هذه الفتره
من الان وحتى اسبوعين ايضا هناك
المرشح الثالث
الذي قال بانه سيعطي اصواته في حال يعني
فضه تحالفه مع حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي وهم الاكراد وهذا يقال بانه من
الصعب ان يحدث لان الاكراد اعطوها الكثير
من الاصوات على سبيل المثال الحصر في ديار
بكر حصد اكثر من 72% من اصواتهم وبالتالي
يطلب منه ذلك يعني هذا صعب وهذا يعني بشكل
غير مباشر بان سنان اوغان يمكن ان يجير
اصواته لاردخان وبالتالي هناك الكثير من
العوامل التي يمكن للجانبين ان يعمل عليها
خلال اسبوعين من اجل
فيما يتعلق بحزب الشعب ورفضه ايضا للنتائج
التي تنشرها وكاله الاناضول فقط ارحب
بالزميل الي حديثنا الان من انقره فاطمه
فهد ومن غازي عنتاب عبد القادر خربوش اهلا
بكم عبد القادر وفاطمه وما اخر المعطيات
حول عمليات الفرز حتى اللحظه في انقره
طيب يبدو انني لا اسمعكم جيدا احمد ولكن
اعتقد انك سالتني عن عمليه الفرز حتى الان
عمليه
يعني من خلفي الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
وفي كل ساعه هناك تحديث من قبل رئيس
الهيئه يخرجون امامنا على المنصه من خلفي
ليتحدث الينا ويعطينا اخر التحديثات هناك
احاديث كبيره تتحدث عن ان يعني المنافسه
اصبحت جدا جدا صعبه خصوصا للمعارضه وحزب
الشعب الجمهوري يعني المحللين يقولون بان
ليفوزك لجدار اوغلو في الجوله الثانيه فهو
يحتاج الى معجزه لماذا يحتاج الى معجزه
احمد لانه يعني بحكم فشل مشروع المعارضه
فقد يعتزل نسبه نسبه من حزب التصويت وهذا
قد نشاهد هبوط في نسبه اصوات كليجدار
اوغلو الاصليه ميرال اكشنار ميلار اكشينار
يعني يقال بانها اصيبت بصدمه من النتائج
وكانت على امل بان تحسم هذه الانتخابات من
الجوله الاولى ولكن ذلك لم يحدث
العداله والتنميه حتى الان لديهم النسبه
الاكبر في الاصوات البرلمانيه بالتالي حتى
وان فازك لجدار اوغلو بالرئاسه يرون بانه
لن يكون قادرا على ممارسه او تحقيق اي من
الاهداف التي يود ان يحققها خصوصا من
ناحيه تحويل البرلمان الى نظام برلماني
وليس رئاسي وتحت حكم فرد واحد طيب
يعني يتمكن كما ذكرت زميلتنا بانه قد
يتمكن من اقناع سنان باعطائه الاصوات
الخمسه في المئه التي تنتمي الى
السنان ولكنه يجب ان يتخلى على الاحد عشره
في المئه من الاصوات الكرديه وذلك طبعا
صعب جدا لانه قد ينزله من نسبه
الاربعينيات الى نسبه الثلاثينات وهذا لن
يقبل به اكيد كريشدار مما يعني بان كما
ذكرت ايضا زميلتنا قد تذهب الاصوات الى
اردوغان وسنان يرغب في الحصول على وزارات
في الحكومه الجديده كما نعلم وهذا الشيء
يصعب المهمه ايضا على كريجدد اوغلو الذي
تقريبا وزع المناصب على تحالفه الائتلافي
ويرى بعض المراقب ايضا بان حتى مع هذا
الائتلاف السداسي او الطاوله السداسيه كما
تسمى لم يتمكن من حسم الانتخابات من
الجوله الاولى وهذه تعطيه يعني نقطه ضعف
او نقطه سلبيه لصالحه يعني حتى مع الاعداد
الكبيره من الاحزاب المتالفه لم يتمكنوا
من الوصول الى الاعداد التي كانوا ياملون
اليها اذا حتى لو لو قبل بشروط اسنان
اوجان والقى خطابات تهاجم حزب الجهبه او
حزبه يعني المسمى بالجاهي في الداخل
التركي في الخامس عشر يوم المقبل فمن
المستحيل ان يحصل على نسبه 5% من اصوات
سنان لان اصلا يقال باننا خبي سنان احمد
هم قوميون متشددون وتقريبا 2% من ناخب
سينان اوغان هم من اصوات محرم انجم محرم
انجي المرشح الرابع الذي انسحب قبل بدايه
الانتخابات اليك احمد طيب فاطمه الى غايه
معالجه الخلل في الصوت او في وصول الصوت
اليك انتقل الان الى عبد القادر خربوش من
غازي عنتاب عبد القادر هل اكتملت عمليه
الفرز في غازي عنتاب وما الذي توفى
المعلومات حول ذلك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
انتخابات بالخصوص فيما يتعلق بالنتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي لم تحسن لحد
اللحظه
لان عديد المكاتب لم يتم او عديد الصناديق
الاقتراع لم يتم فرزها لحد الان بحسب
تصريح رئيس الهيئه العليا للانتخابات التي
قال بانه تم جرى فرز حتى الان 99 بالمئه
فقط من صناديق الاقتراع داخل تركيا وتبقى
27 صندوقا لم يفرز بعد فيما يعمل الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان ان تحدث اصوات صناديق
الفرز للداء الخارج الفارق وتحسن هذا
السباق الانتخابي لصالحه بحيث صرح رئيس
الهيئه العليا الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
التركيه بانه جرى فقط فرز
84.06 بالمئه من صناديق الاختراع في
الخارج وعدد الصناديق المتبقيه الى اللحظه
هو 9
1594 صندوقا الذي تمت يعني فرزه فيما تبقى
1529 صندوق لم يتم فرزه لحد اللحظه نتحدث
ايضا عن الانتخابات البرلمانيه والتي تم
نشر نتائجها تقريب بصفه يعني اوليه بحيث
يتصدر حزب العداله والتنميه بتحالفه
النتائج بمئتين وسته مقعدا وقد احدث
تراجعا مقارنه مع اعداد المقاعد التي كان
يحوزها في البرلمان
المنقضيه ولايته
[تصفيق]
295 مقعدا وتراجع الى الى
266 مقعدا متبوعا بحزب الشعب الجمهوري
ب168 مقعدا هذه كل الارقام لنتائج الاوليه
في انتظار الاعلان عما توصلت اليه عمليات
الفرز النهائيه
لتتضح صوره النتائج الاوليه النهائيه حتى
يعني يتاكد الجميع من
جدليه الذهاب الى دوره انتخابيه ثانيه من
عدمها وهذا ما اقلق وادخل انصار يعني كلا
الطرفين بالخصوص تيار حزب رجب طيب اردوغان
عقد العداله والتنميه
[تصفيق]
وادخلهما في تصريحات مضاده ناريه ليله امس
جعلت الجميع يفقد بوصلته في تحليل على
الاقل نتائج هذه الانتخابات التي كانت
مفاجئه ومتباينه منذ غلق مكاتب الاقتراع
بالامس في حدود الساعه الخامسه والارقام
تتغير بين الفينه والاخرى بين الدقائق
الدقائق واحيانا الثواني عند بدايه الفرز
كان كان حزب او كان رجب طيب اردوغان
النتائج بفارق كبير بدا وكانه حسم المعركه
الانتخابيه في ساعاتها الاولى
حين كان بلغ اكثر من 65% من الاصوات لكن
عاد لمنحا تنازلي في حدود الساعه العاشره
ليلا وبدات المعطيات تتغير وبدات ملامح
وهذا بشكل مفاجاه لجميع المتابعين هذه
الانتخابات عبد القادر ان اعترف منك الوقت
وسنكتفي بهذا القدر اشك لكم مفيدي العربيه
من غاز عنتاب عبد القادر الخربوش وكريس من
اسطنبول وفاطمه فهد ايضا من انقره وترك
معكم في متابعه هذا اليوم لتطورات هذه
الانتخابات والمعطيات ايضا مشاهدينا اعلنا
رئيس اللجنه العليا للانتخابات التركيه
احمد ان النتائج حتى الان تعني ان
الانتخابات ستمضي باتجاه اجراء جوله جوله
اعاده بين اردوغان وتلو في 28 من مايو
الجاري نتابع
حتى الساعه 9:45 صباحا تم فتح
192,187 صندوقا للاقتراع وعدد صناديق
الاقتراع غير المفتوحه سبعه وعشرين حصل
المرشح رجب طيب اردوغان على
49.40
وكماركلشدار اوغلو على
44.96%
والمرشح سنان اوغان على
خمسه.2% حتى هذه اللحظه
رئيسه على ما يبدو الاقرار بتراجع تقدمه
متهم المعارضه بانها تحاول خداع الشعب
القول انها متقدمه وقال لا احد يعلم نتائج
على وجه الدقه وفرز الاصوات سيستمر في
الداخل والخارج مرجحا ان يفوز في الكلمه
ذاتها مشاهدين التي القاها امام انصاره
عاد وقال انه سيحترم اذا حسم الام اذا حسب
الامر بجوله الاعاده
داعيا الشعب ان يتحلى باليقظه لحين انتهاء
عد الاصوات
[موسيقى]
بلادنا في انتخابات 14 من مايو شهدت عرسا
ديمقراطيا نعم النتائج النهائيه لم تظهر
بعد لكننا متقدمون بفرق شاسع هم يعلمون
انهم كانوا يخدعون الناس بقولهم انهم
متقدمون في النتائج لكننا لسنا مثلهم نحن
صادقون ومخلصون النتائج النهائيه لم تظهر
بعد ونحن ننتظر اعلانها بشكل رسمي ومعلن
نحن ننتظر تجلى شرعيتنا في النتائج
النهائيه
[موسيقى]
جداول الانتخابات ستظهر الفائز بشكل واضح
لا يقبل الشك وبلادنا هي الفائزه في
الانتخابات مهما كانت النتيجه ان نسبه
المشاركه في هذه الانتخابات هي الاكبر في
تاريخنا السياسي نحن ننتظر من الجميع هذا
النضج الديمقراطي واتمنى ان تمر هذه
الانتخابات دون ان نشهد اي امر مؤسف
النقاشات التي كانت في مراحل الحملات
الانتخابيه باتت ورائنا وفي هذا الاطار
قال شعبنا كلمته ويجب احترام ذلك اننا
نتجاوز اقرب منافس لنا بمليونين و600 الف
صوت وانا واثق من ان الارقام في صناديق
الاقتراع ستزداد اكثر فاكثر نحن نؤمن
بقدرتنا على الفوز بالانتخابات من الجوله
الاولى واذا كان قرار الشعب اجراء جوله
ثانيه فذلك مرحب به
مرشح تحالف المعارضه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه التركيه كريشتار اوغلو من جانبه
اذاعه في تغريده على حسابه الرسمي دعم
رقيب الانتخابات بعدم ترك مقاعدهم وطالب
لجنه الانتخابات الوطنيه باعلان البيانات
القادمه من جميع الولايات اوغلو اكد ان
نسبه الخياليه التي اظهرت في بدايه التي
ظهرت في بدايه فرز الاصوات بل اظهرت تقدم
اردوغان بنسبه 60% تراجعت الان الى 50%
وبالتالي لم يحصل اردوغان على نتيجه التي
يريدها في انتخابات الاحد بحسب كليشته
بدون افتراض على الرغم من كل حملاته
التشييريه والشتائم لم يحصل اردوغان على
النتيجه التي توقعها لا ينبغي لاحد ان
يتحمس لامر واقع لا يتم الفوز بالانتخابات
من على الشرفه ولا تزال نتائج الانتخابات
تتوالى اذا قررت امتنا اجراء جوله الاعاده
فعلى الرحب والسعه سنفوز بالتاكيد في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات وسيرى
الجميع ذلك
النتيجه تعلن في اقصر وقت ممكن لم يعد
بامكان هذا البلد ان يتسامح مع عدم اليقين
لا تخاف من اراده الشعب ادعو المجلس
الاعلى للانتخابات لاتحلى بالمسؤوليه لقد
وقعنا الوثائق لا تدعو الجمهور يصف
انتباهه اكرر لا تعطلوا ارادتها هذه الامه
اناشد ايضا المتطوعين في مجال الديمقراطيه
الموجودين حاليا في الميدان الا يتركوا
صناديق الاقتراع والمجالس الانتخابيه ابدا
نحن هنا حتى يتم احتساب كل صوت شكرا
للصحفيين الاعزاء
مشاهدين من اسطنبول ينضموا الى السيد طه
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيئتها
معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه
زميلتنا فاطمه فهد قبل قليل تقول نقلا عن
محللين ومراقبين ان زعيم المعارض اوغلو
يحتاج الى معجزه لكي يفوز في الجوله
الثاني من هذا الانتخابات هل تتفق مع هذا
الطرح
تحياتي لك يا استاذ احمد والاستاده
المشاهدين نعم وخاصه تحدثنا عن ان مفتاح
الفوز في الجوله الثانيه هو سوف يكون سنان
اوجان خاصه انه حصل على نسبه كبيره وكانت
غير متوقعه ومفاجئه خمسه بالمئه بالامس
كريستال اولو اجرى اتصال مع سنان ولكن
تعلم ان هذا الحزب او تحالف الاجداد هو من
متطرف
يميني بشكل كبير وهو يرفض التحالف
تحالف الامه وتحالف حزب الشعب الجمهوري مع
الاكراد وحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي لذا حاليا
كافه استطاعات وكافه الاراء تتحدث بانه من
الممكن ان يتحالف على انه اعذب بالامس انه
لن يعطي او لن يدعم اي حزب في اي مرشح في
الجوله الثانيه لكن انا التصوري اعتقد منذ
يعني بعد ساعات الاعلان بشكل رسمي
الجوله الثانيه تبدا الصفقات وتبدا
المساومات ما بين الطرفين وخاصه ان كان
اردوغان ومع سيناء اوجان او حتى
فيما يتعلق يعني دعم هذا المرشح هو مرور
او الفوز بهذه الانتخابات المصريه والهامه
ونحن نتحدث عن الانتخابات الاصعب في حياه
اردوغان السياسيه هل تعتقد ان اردوغان
سيحافظ على تقدمه في الجوله الثانيه ايضا
يعني بالامس حقيقه كان التصريح اردوغان
كان هو نوعا ما هناك دبلوماسي بشكل واضح
عندما اتحدث
انهم هم واثقون من الفوز بالجوله الاولى
وخاصه في ساعات الليل كانت هناك اصوات
الخارج تفتح ونسبه من اصوات الخارج هي
مؤيده بشكل كبير لرئيس اردوغان لكنه ترك
الباب مفتوحا وتحدث اذا يعني
توجهنا الى جوله الثانيه فنحترم اراده
الشعب يعني انا التصوري اعتقد يعني هناك
وحسب الاستطلاعات وحسب يعني الاراء خلال
الساعات الاخيره الماضيه هناك حقيقه خيبه
امل هي يعني اصابه المعارضه التركيه في
السابق وفي الايام الاخيره الحكومه
التركيه والحكومه اردوغان او تحالف
اردوغان كان يتحدثون يعني بشكل منطقي عن
الفوز في الانتخابات الرئاسيه 51 الى 52%
لكن السيد كما يشتغل اورو كان وضع السقف
عالي جدا
وهذا حقيقه يعني كانت هي اصابه
انصارهم بشكل كبير وهذا يعني
هذا هو خطا في الحسابات يلعب ربما على وتر
تحفيز الناخب التركي لتصويت الاول
ولتحالفه ايضا
يعني الاثنين معا هناك خطا في الحسابات
وهذا ليست المره الاولى يعني اساسيات كمان
يتحدث اذا لم احصل على 40% سوف استقيل حتى
هذه اللحظه ما زال موجودا فيما يتعلق كان
هناك يريد التحفيز وخاصه بانه حقيقه وجد
فرصه كبيره للمره الاولى المعارضه التركيه
تتحد تحت سقف واحد وحقيقه كان له يعني
شريحه كبيره مؤيده خلال الفتره الاخيره
كما تبعنا جميعا وحتى ان الجميع كان يتحدث
بانه هو يعني الرئيس القادم وممكن ان
يستطيع ان يسحب البساط من تحت اقدام
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ولكن دائما هناك
من يقول بان الرئيس اردوغان من خلال خبرته
في السياسه هو دائما يحرز الاهداف في
الدقائق الاخيره وهذا ما حصل حقيقه يعني
كان هناك استراتيجيه واضحه لا تغيير في
التحركات اقصد الحملات الانتخابيه وكان
هناك الهدوء ويعني الاتقان يعني اذا اتبعت
بالامس الخطاب الذي الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان استمر عشرين دقيقه كانوا حماسي
وكان هو قريب جدا من انصاره كان هناك
الالاف من الحاضرون بعكس الخطاب الذي
القاه كريستال اورو دقيقتان وكان حقيقه
هناك الغضب والحزم والقلق هو الصفه او
السائده على الوجوه العدد الاعداد القليله
التي تواجدت في قاعه غرفه المؤتمرات طيب
وسط هذا تم كبير من المناوشات والتجاذبات
ايضا بين المرشحين هل تعتقد ان المناخ
السياسيه الان مهيئ لجوله ثانيه من هذا
الانتخابات خلال هذا السقف الزمنيه المحدد
باسبوعين فقط نتحدث عن الثامن والعشرين من
مايو الجاري
انا التصور اعتقد يعني حاليا هناك في
الفتره الاخيره كان الحديث دائما عن
الاستقطاب الحديث عن فوضى وقلق وخوف يعني
فيما يتعلق بان تتحول هذه الازمه يعني او
نسميه العرس الديمقراطي الذي دائما تشهده
تركيا الى ازمه يعني سياسيه قضائيه حتى
امنيه ولكن تركيا والرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
دائما وضع الخطوط العريضه تحت هذه الكلمات
بانه يجب الحفاظ على الامن واستقرار ان
تركيا حقيقه لا تتحمل في هذا الوقت في ظل
الازمات التي تمر بها اقصد هنا على راسها
الازمه الاقتصاديه وايضا ان هناك حاله من
الضجر لدى شريحه كبيره من الشباب فاذا
تحولت هذه
الامور الى هذه من اعطى فلا اتصور اعتقد
الخاسر الاكبر هل الجهه التي سوف تقوم
بهذا العمل وتخسر شريحه كبيره لذا نلاحظ
ان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان تحدث وقال اذا
لم
ننجح فيها في الانتخابات سوف نحترم ارا
الشعب وايضا يعني بالامس كان هناك السيد
تحدث يعني زهر من الساعات الاولى بان
الرئيس القادم هو كمال على عكس عمر تشيليك
حزب العداله والتنميه قال لا نستطيع عنا
معلومات اننا نحن متقدمين ولا اركن لا
نستطيع
الافصاح عنها احتراما للاراده الوطنيه في
تركيا شكرا لكم اسطنبول كنت معنا طه عوده
اوغلو الكاتب والمحلل السياسي تحيه سيرتها
نشاطنا مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
في سباق البرلماني حزب اردوغان يحقق تقدما
حتى
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اذا تعكسوا
نتائج انقساما عميقا في بلد على مفترق طرق
سياسي فحتى النتائج الاول النتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات البرلمانيه اظهرت تقدم
الملحوظه للتحالف اردوغان ومن المتوقع ان
يحقق التحالف اردوغان اغلبيه في البرلمان
الامر الذي يمنحه تقدما محتملا على بل قبل
جوله الاعاده حيث وصلت نسبه الفرز بنسبه
لتحالف الجمهور الى
49%.32 بينما حصل تحالف الشعب المعارض على
35% فاصله ثلاثه وعشرين من الاصوات ويليه
تحالف العمل والحريه الكردي بنسبه 10%
فاصل ثمانيه واربعين ثم تحالف الاجداد
بنسبه اثنين في المئه فاصله 45 اما
بالنسبه اما النسبه الاقل كانت تحالف
الوحده الكبرى بواقع 1% فاصله واحد من
عشره وبالنسبه لعدد المقاعد البرلمانيه
وصل العدد بنسبه لحزب العداله والتنميه
وحزب الشعب الجمهوري
168 بينما وصل عدد المقاعد
لحزب الحركه القوميه الى واحد وخمسين اما
الحزب الجيد فاربعه واربعين وحزب اليسار
اثنين
وحزب اليسار الاخضر طبعا وحزب الرفاه
الجديد خمسه مقاعد اما بالنسبه لحزب
الاتحاد الكبير وحزب الظفر وحزب البلد فلم
يحققه اي نتيجه تذكر
التحالفات السياسيه التركيه المتنافسه
الائتلاف الحاكم يضم حزب العداله والتنميه
حزب الحركه القوميه
حزب الوحده الكبرى او الاتحاد الكبير
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من انقر ينضموا دكتور باسل الحاج
جاسم الباحث في العلاقات الدولي اهلا بك
دكتور باسل الضيف السابق تهض اوغلو كان
يتحدث عن ان سنان اوغان رغم انه اعلن عدم
مساندته لاي طرف من الاطراف في هذا السباق
الانتخابي الا ان ذلك ربما يبقى رهينا
بتفاهمات وصفقات الغرف المغلقه بعد
الاعلان عن الجوله الثانيه ما رايك
صباح الخير لك وللمشاهدين الكرام
بالتاكيد اليوم دور
المرشح الثالث سنان اوغان الذي يمكن وصفه
بالحصان الاسود في هذه الانتخابات سيكون
له تاثير كبير في الجوله القادمه اذا ما
اتجهنا اليها وكل يعني المؤشرات تشير
باننا ذاهبون الى جوله ثانيه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
هذا طبعا يعتمد على الكلام الذي تحدث به
هذا المرشح قبل عده ايام حيث اشاره بوضوح
الى انه جاهز
للاتفاق او تلقي العروض من المرشحين بخصوص
السلطه القادمه سواء كان منصب وزاري او
نائبا للرئيس ومعروف توجهه القومي اليميني
المتطرف
وهو يعني من المستبعد مثلا ان يدعم او
يتحالف مع مرشح تحالف ما يطلق عليه تحالف
الامه
ومرشحه هو كمالك الجدار اوغلو رئيس حزب
الشعب الجمهوري بسبب تحالف الاخير مع حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي صاحب الجذور الكرديه
وهذا قد يجعله اقرب ربما
لحزب الحركه القوميه الذي انشق عنه
بالاساس لكنه مع ذلك لم يصدر اي اساءات
لزعيمه لدوله بهجله قد يكون اقرب لهذا
التحالف تحالف الجمهور او تحالف الشعب
الذي
يتزعمه او مرشحه رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس
الحالي لكن ايضا عامل اخر قد يكون له
تاثير وهو حصول التحالف الاخر تحالف رجل
طيب اردوغان على اغلبيه في البرلمان هذا
قد يجعل الكثير من الناخبين يغيرون
تصويطهم ويتوجهون
لرجل طيب اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه بسبب
عدم الرغبه بحدوث يعني تناقض او تضارب في
السلطات او جمود سياسي في المرحله المقبله
اذا ما
استمروا في اعطاء صوتهم لكمال كالجدار
اوغلو
وايضا الفارق في الاصوات اليوم هناك خمسه
بالمئه فارق بين
اردوغانو الجوله الثانيه لا تحتاج الى
يعني الفوز بما هو اعلى من الخمسين بالمئه
ايا كانت النسبه المهم ان يتقدم احد
المرشحين على الاخر تكفي ليكون فائزا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه يعني هذه من العوامل
الرئيسيه التي يمكن ان تحدد الفائز في
الجوله الاخر ايضا حول الجوله الثانيه سيد
باسل يعني الذهاب للجوله الثانيه هل يعني
بالضروره المضيئه مضي الطرفين بذات
الاسلوب وذات النسق الذي ادارى به الجوله
الاولى امام عليهما ربما تقديم رؤى
واطروحات مختلفه لاستماره اكبر قدر من
الناخبين خاصه اصحاب الاصوات المتدببه
هذا سؤال محوري بالتاكيد خلال الاسبوعين
القادمين ليجند يكون الحديث عن تداعيات
الزلزال او المواضيع التي جرى الحديث عنها
طويلا خلال الاسابيع القليله الماضيه هنا
قد يلعب دور الكاريزما والخبره التي يتمتع
بها رجل طيب اردوغان عاملا مساعدا يتميز
به عن المرشح الاخر بالاضافه طبعا
لعامل خيبه الامل الذي تعرضت له المعارضه
مع وجود هذا العدد الكبير من الاحزاب
المختلفه
من حيث
التوجهات ومع ذلك لم تستطيع ان تجعل
مرشحها يجتاز هذه الانتخابات من الجوله
الاولى هذا يعتبر فشل قد يؤثر على اداء
هذا التحالف خلال الاسبوعين القادمين وقد
يكون له ايضا
سلبيه نعرف انه منذ البدايه لم يكن هناك
توقف توافق كامل على ترشيح كمالك الجدار
اوغلو واعلنت عن ذلك رئيسه حزب الجيد
ميرال اكشنار وحتى انها ان انسحبت من
التحالف ثم عادت اليه قد تكون بعض الاطراف
ايضا لديها نفس التحفظ لكنها لم تكشف عنه
خيبه الامل والفشل الذي حصل في الجوله
الاولى قد يكون له تاثير سلبي خلال
الاسبوعين القادمين ويكون هذا عامل اضافي
مساعد للطرف الاخر
للمرشح رجب طيب اردوغان الرئيس الحالي
يعني نجد ان كل العوامل تصب في صالح
اردوغان اكثر منها لصالح الاصدار
نحو الجوله الثانيه نعم شكرا لك من انقره
كنت معنا الدكتور باسير الحاج جاسم الباحث
في العلاقات الدوليه تحيه الدكتور باسل
الاحزاب السياسيه في تركيا
حزب العداله والتنميه حزب اسلامي محافظ
يتراسه رجب طيب اردوغان
لديه 295 نائبا بالبرلمان هو الحزب الحاكم
منذ 2002
تشكل من قبل نواب منشقين عن حزب الفضيله
الاحزاب السياسيه في تركيا
حزب الشعب الجمهوري حزب علماني يتراسه
كمال كالجدار اوغلو
[موسيقى]
لديه 106 نائبا بالبرلمان هو اقدم حزب
سياسي تاسس عام 1919
اكبر الاحزاب المعارضه للحزب الحاكم
[موسيقى]
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
وثائق استخباراتي امريكيه تكشف عن تخطيط
رئيس فاجنر لخيانه روسيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معركه ارقام بين اردوغان وتجدار المرشحان
يستعدان الجوله اعاده غير مسبوقه في تاريخ
تركيا
اردوغان يتهم المعارضه بالخداع ويؤكد
تقدمه يتعهد بهزيمته ويدعو لحساب اخر صوت
يواصل حشد المزيد من الدعم العسكري قبل
المعركه المضاده وقواته تحقق اول تقدم في
محيط بخموت
صمود الهدنه في قطاع غزه والقوات
الاسرائيليه تقتل شابا فلسطينيا خلال
اقتحامها مدينه نابلس
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد يواصلوا الرئيس
الاوكرانيزيا جولته في اوروبا لحشد مزيد
من الدعم العسكري قبل المعركه المضاده
المرتقبه بعد زياره ايطاليا والمانيا
وفرنسا وصل اليوم الى بريطانيا حيث عقد
لقاء مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
في مقره الريفي في تشيكرز واكدت حكومه
ريشيسوناك انها ستقوم بارسال المزيد من
مئات من صواريخ الدفاع الجوي ومئات من
الطائرات بدون طيار جديده طويله المدى
انه سيجرم فوضى هامه في بريطانيا مشيرا
الى انها لعبت دورا رائدا في توسيع قدراتك
العسكريه برا وجوا كما شدد سوناك على ان
هذه اللحظه حاسمه بل ان هذه لحظه حاسمه في
مقاومه اوكرانيا لحرب عدوانيه وروعه لم
يختاروها او يثيرها على حد وصفه
بموازاه جوله زينسكي لحشد الدعم اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني عن اول نجاح لهجومه في
محيط مدينه باخم الشرقيه اوكرانيا التي
تشهد اطول واعنف معركه في اطار الحرب في
اوكرانيا واكد قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه
في المدينه هو اول نجاح منذ صيف الماضي
مشيرا الى انه الى ان اهداف روسيا لن
تتغير للسيطره على باحمد المحاصره ويتم
حاليا ارسال قوات هجوميه روسيه جديده الى
ضواحيها
من جانبها
لروسيا اي تراجع للقوات الروسيه في باخ
موث مؤكده مضيئه في السيطره على القطاع
الغربي من المدينه وقال رئيس سلطه دونيسكو
ان القوات الروسيه سيطرت على مرتفعات مهمه
في غرب بخمو وتتصدى لجميع الهجمات التي
تشنها القوات الاوكرانيه واضاف ان القوات
الروسيه تسيطر على ما يقرب من 90% من
اراضي ولكن الوضع فيها يبقى متوترا مع
تكثيف اوكرانيا هجماتها على طول خطوط
التماس
هذا وكشفت وثائق مخابرات امريكيه مسربه ان
رئيس مجموعه العسكري
عرض الكشف عن مواقع عن مواقع القوات
الروسيه الحكومه الاوكرانيه بحسب صحيفه
واشنطن بوست في يناير من خلال اتصالاته
بجهاز المخابرات الاوكراني للكشف عن مواقع
القوات الروسيه مقابل سحب اوكرانيا
لجنودها من بخمه بغيه سيطره عليها وجاء رد
اوكرانيا بالرفض
افادت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان مسيرات
نشنت هجوم على قاعده جويه روسيه على بعد
150 كيلومترا شمال الحدود الاوكرانيه في
الثالث من مايو ورجحت الوزاره في تقرير
نشرته على تويتر ان يكون الهجوم الحق ضررا
بالغا باحدى طائرات النقل الثقيل التابع
لطيران النقل العسكري الروسي واوضحت
الدفاع البريطانيه ان روسيا تستخدم هذه
القاعده لاطلاق المسيرات الايرانيه
لمهاجمه الاراضي الاوكرانيه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان ليهاوي
ممثل الصين الخاص لشؤون منطقه اوروبا
واسيا وسفير بكين السابق لدى روسيا سيبدا
جوله تشمل
ودولا اوروبيه اخرى في مهمه نحو بحث سبل
التوصل الى تسويه سياسيه للازمه
الاوكرانيه واكدت الخارجيه في بيانها ان
زياره هذا المبعوث دليل على جهود الصين في
تعزيز محادثات السلام وتوضح مدى التزامها
الوثيق بهذا النوع من المفاوضات ومن
المقرر ان تكون اوكرانيا المحطه الاولى في
جولته وفقا لمصادر مطلعه على الامر
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه مقتل شاب
فلسطيني واصابه اخر برصاص اسرائيلي برصاص
اسرائيلي خلال اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه
لمخيم عسكر في نابلس واقتحمت القوات
الاسرائيليه مدينه نابلس من عده محاور
واندلعت مواجهات في مخيم عسكر القديم وحي
المساكن الشعبيه في المدينه
وفي غزه مشاهدينا صمدت الهدنه حتى الان
وكشفت مقاطع مصوره التقطت بواسطه طائره من
دون الطيار حجم الدمار المنازل المتضرره
جراء الغارات الاسرائيليه على القطاع التي
استمرت لخمسه ايام متواصله
[موسيقى]
يحيي الفلسطينيون اليوم الذكرى الخامسه
والسبعين للنكبه حيث تنطلق ومن رام الله
مسيره العوده من امام ضريح الرئيس ياسر
عرفات نحو المركز الرئيسي للمدينه وستنطلق
ايضا صافره حداد لمده 75 ثانيه عبر سماعات
المساجد والاذاعات المحليه واجراس الكنائس
والتلفزيون حيث من المقرر ان يلقي رئيس
الحكومه الفلسطينيه كلمه في هذه المناسبه
اضافه لكلمه اخرى سيلغيها الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس تزامنا مع انطلاق
المسيره في مقر الامم المتحده بنيويورك
مشاهدينا في تطورات الميدانيه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع اتهم الاخير
قوات الجيش بشن هجمات جويه على مناطق
ماهوله بالمدنيين في العاصمه الخرطوم
بالاضافه الى استهداف مستشفى شرق النيل
وقالت قوات الدعم السريع ان هذا الهجوم
ادى الى مقتل واصابه العشرات من المواطنين
وتدمير جزء كبير من المستشفى
قوات الدعم السريعه الفريق محمد حمدانو
المعروف بسمحي متي الاخبار التي تتحدث عن
مقتله في تسجيل صوتي نشره عبر حساب في
تويتر مؤكدا انه يتجول في جل مناطق
العاصمه الخرطوم كما دعا قائد قوات الدعم
السريع افراد قواته الى محاربه من اسمائهم
باللصوص ومساعده الشعب السوداني وتلبيه
احتياجاته
الكريم الانقلابيين شغالين دعايات وشغالين
نشاط هدام انا الان متجول داخل القوات في
بحر موجود في ام درمان موجود في الخرطوم
موجود في شرق النيل موجود والان هم روجوا
لمقتل محمد حمدان فادي دعايات ودي كلها
اكاذيب بيدل على انه هم مغلوبين
رساله لاشابه قوات الدعم السريع انتم حماه
الوطن المواطن السودان امانه في عناقكم
احمل الناس سعد الضعيف تواصلوا مع
المواطنين في الاحياء اعرفوا احتياجاتهم
حاربوا المتفلتين والحراميه الذين يرون
الناس
الانجلابيين شغالين مؤامرات عايزين يدمروا
السودان واهله ونحن لهم بالمرصاد نحن
مستعدين لمساعده وتوفير الخدمات الضروريه
في اماكن شجره قواتنا
في ظل انعدام الطعام للعالقين في مطار
الفلوج بجنوب السودان بدات عدد من النساء
باعداد وبيع اطعمه محليه لسد الحاجه
الغذائيه باسعار معقوله يبيع من مطار فلوج
جنوب السودان والتفاصيل
هنا الا بوابه مطار فلوج بجنوب السودان
ازدهرت حركه تجاريه نسويه من الاطيبه
البحريه لسد حاجه العالقين من الطعام
باسعار زهيده فالناس هنا يعانون الانتظاره
وقله الطعام
نازل كانوا تعبانين
بلينا اشترينا الرز وعدس وجنجاره ونعمل
مدينه حاجات
نازل تعبانين يعني بتلقى واحد عنده 100
جنيه بيجيب لك انا جيعان ادينا
فيما استقرت الهام سليمان التي تقطن منطقه
جودا الشماليه الاباء المانجه لسد حاجه
الاسره التي تعاني اوضاء مائشيه صعبه
بعدما فقد رب المنزل وظيفته اليوميه نتيجه
لحاله الحرب في البلاد
اذا هكذا تبدو الصوره فالجميع يشكو من
انعدام السيوله وبصعوبه يستطيع النازه
تغطيه مصاريف وجبه واحده ناهيك من مياح
الشرب عند المويه قدامك
وبعدين انا لا يصير 5 يوم والله الا قاعد
نمشي ناكل معاهم
وما بين هذا وذاك ستظل الحرب واثارها صوره
معلمه في اذهان الكثيرين فمن حرب من الحرب
واجهته حرب اخرى
مصائبكم عند قوم فوائد وان كانت متفاوته
في اسعار الاطعمه التي تعرض هنا الا انها
استطاعت ان تسد حاجه الكثيرين في ظل عظام
الطعام هنا
العربيه مطار فلوج جنوب السودان وفي ختام
هذه الاخباريه مشاهدينا نذكر بعبرز
العناوين
[تصفيق]
معركه ارقام بين اردوغانو المرشحان
يستعدان لجوله اعاده غير مسبوقه في تاريخ
تركيا
اردوغان يتهم المعارضه بالخداع ويؤكد
تقدمه يتعهد بهزيمته ويدعو لحساب اخر صوت
جينسكي يواصل حشد مزيد من الدعم العسكري
قبل المعركه المضاده وقواته تحقق اول تقدم
في محيط
صمود الهدنه في قطاع غزه والقوات
الاسرائيليه تقتل شابا فلسطينيا خلال
اقتحامها مدينه نابلس
في امان الله مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات